are you lacking love it's a chance to
write some old wrongs Italy in the
quarterfinals an opportunity to face the
demons of world cup 2006 and euro 2012
when Italy denied Germany chances at
glory we haven't kind Italian drama
we're not suffering Italy trauma horny I
don't think it's useful to draw on past
events how bites eat this ish that's
called coffee we'd rather have a fresh
espresso and we must see to it that it
tastes very good this weekend darksea
coach Mick but love knows Italy have
been on good form so far in Euro 2016
and they're the most veteran team in the
tournament players with depth of
experience now peaking physically tamaki
home is sought it and I opponents the
space even teams as good as Spain can't
find a way through it won't be easy to
penetrate their defensive lines the
coaching staff are working on different
tactics to help our players unlock their
defense oh my ambition tifton umbrella
teamer the coaches tactical tinkering is
happening behind closed doors at the
team hotel meanwhile on the training
pitch not a player in sight as they've
been given a break at Lake Geneva I feel
it when he had an individual lot of them
are training individually in the gym
lifting weights and exercising quite a
few of them playing volleyball going for
a run or enjoying a bike ride they never
sit still I think it's great that they
mix things up a little on their days off
smacking on active a Canadian by
Saturday the German machine expects to
be well oiled and fully recharged ready
to face Italy in Bordeaux
you